my main emotion was just kind of
heartbreak and how can I help former
bachelor Sean Lowe lives in Dallas with
his family and Sunday night felt
compelled to help his fellow Texans
devastated by hurricane Harvey in
Houston he put out the call on Twitter
asking his almost 800,000 followers if
anyone had a boat he could borrow it was
that simple and soon he was driving to
Houston alone
ét spoke to him Tuesday morning after he
returned home just to go down a
residential street on a boat and you see
water eight feet high in people's homes
it's it's a really eerie feeling and to
hear people yelling and shouting and we
came across a man who was in cardiac
arrest yesterday and I don't I don't
know if he survived I doubt that he did
and we had to pull him from a canoe that
he was being drugged in into our boat
where firefighters were giving him CPR
for about 15 or 20 minutes until we
could get him into an ambulance I'll
never forget that ever I mean I it took
about three of us and I was holding a
dead man as his heart was not beating
and his face was as blue as blue gets
and just to be involved with that and to
see it it really shook me up and that's
just yes that's something that I'll take
to my grave remembering low thinks he
helped about a dozen people he isn't
looking for attention just to try to
raise awareness and he's planning to
head back to Houston and help more
donations are probably and tremendously
and if you can get down there they need
you and right now I'm trying to figure
out how I can get back down there to to
lend more of a helping hand
you
[Music]